a long delayed win for u.s president joe
biden and his hugely expensive plans to
regenerate america in the last hour the
house of representatives has passed a
one trillion dollar infrastructure bill
directing funding into programs
including road and bridge building
but an even bigger package the build
back better act covering welfare and
environmental spending remains stalled
by infighting
biden cancelled
a weekend trip in an attempt to unite
progressives and moderates in his
divided democratic party
now um we will go on the line to our
correspondent
uh stefan simons who is joining us from
washington
uh stefan
this plan got through very late on a
friday evening
how did house speaker nancy pelosi
secure the numbers after what was a day
of democratic infighting
yeah you know that wasn't as it was
planned today began actually good with
good numbers from the
job report 4.6
unemployment rate the lowest yet and 530
000 jobs created in october so that was
good news for the white house and for
the dams for the democrats in
uh
in congress but then the democrats
managed to squander it all away and it
took nancy pelosi and president biden in
the evening hours and into the night
hours um to intervene and and to really
negotiate again to make at least this
package this 1.2 trillion bipartisan
infrastructure bill um go through the
house with 22 8
votes 4 and 206 against it by the way 13
republicans voted with the majority of
democrats and about six democrats voted
against it so that doesn't look good for
the democrats but the good news here is
for democrats for
uh president biden and the white house
is that this package at least uh went
through so far okay and we are just
following those live pictures of the
proceedings
uh in congress there uh as uh this
vote has uh just gone through uh back to
you stefan how much of a victory is this
for president joe biden who was working
the numbers very late on friday night in
washington
well
it's huge actually it's monumental even
if it's just half of what his economic
initiatives are remember there's a 1.75
trillion
social spending bill still as you
mentioned on the table not negotiated
not decided on and there's where all the
climate change money is days where
social initiatives are anchored but no
doubt this is just the infrastructure
bill now through uh against all the
expectations throughout the course of
the day when we all had that means all
journalists and observers
in the capital in washington had given
up on the democrats being able to pass
this this is a major success for uh mr
biden and he will have that bill on his
desk tomorrow and is expected to sign it
stefan you mentioned that this is the
infrastructure bill but what about the
welfare and climate package the
so-called build back better act
right that's uh that's still uh in
negotiations that's 1.75 trillion
dollars
uh which are needed for those programs
as you know there's those problems like
lower taxes for a lower income
people who make have lower incomes
family leave but also money which is
spent on clean energy on on climate
change or to prevent climate change from
even getting worse here in the united
states and everywhere else so this is
still needed this is still negotiated
and where in the senate this bill which
passed now the house is agreed again
already in the senate that was a
bipartisan bill so it can go to the
president and he could sign it
infrastructure social spending bill
which is still outstanding there is um
one or two democratic senators one is
fairly
famous now here in the us and that's
senator manchin from west virginia
that has still to be negotiated so this
is ongoing and this is not a done deal
this could take another few weeks
okay
uh stefan simons in washington thank you
and as we uh take one more look at those
um live pictures coming through
from congress